blog mas giorno 2 ciao ragazzi sono i
guglielmo del futuro è questo qui è un
piccolo avvertimento questo blog sempre
più con fio come arriviamo il 24 di
questo passo del 24 arrivo persona rana
te l'avevo detto battute così squallide
ci saranno per tutta la durata del video
palo sentiamo questo spirito del natale
no nessuno lo sente nessuno ti vuole
bene e sento lo sciacquone successo che
viene scaricata la prossima cosa bini e
scaricata sarà la tua testa e la magia
del natale non la senti non le respiri
guardano nessun agro di natale stanno
costruendo l'albero e dei centri
fretta mi faranno
sono belli di legge fa meno tipo
l'albero soprattutto dei luce
ed è una piramide oggi una ziggurat o
delle palle che si stanno facendo le
persone a guardare questo video
penso di fare anche io comunque una cosa
così discreta per per questo natale a
quello che devo fare pure l'albero è sì
dai
per carità ma poi devi togliere io c'ho
ancora la roba di halloween
secondo me quei ragni si staccheranno da
soli
questa è la darsena e la darsena il
posto in cui io e lui ci siamo
incontrati per la prima volta e per la
seconda e per la terza quarta quinta
finché a un certo punto io ho odiato la
darsena non la regge volpino
invece adesso luigi non mi sopporta più
è questo il sorriso di un'ora di odio ma
che è che mette i cigni nei laghi cioè
sono i cigni che vengono da soli e cioè
un'agenzia di cigni che rimette i laghi
non è un lago booster una persona che
mette i cigni nelle barre se ne sono
successo nei cibi che amano
particolarmente le darsene o sono i di
dar senologi che mette vicini essere per
fare scendere anche perché non c'erano i
cigni le 20mila volte in cui siamo
venuti qua no mi ha detto lui che questa
è la casa di babbo natale
[Musica]
e che fanno
durante durati più di natale sono una
fila chilometrica di bimbi che aspettano
di farsi la foto con lui che è dentro a
incontrare proprio dovete mangiare non
ramellini e questo signore che fa babbo
natale sta là dentro verrà probabilmente
dieci giorni ci ritorna a roma sono
molto triste e tu sei affranto afflitto
non riesce a riprendersi ma per coprire
l'impianto
pensi che riuscirà a prendere sonno
stanotte
è la faremo
nel lettone calcolate che il letto di
lui è più associabile una bara che è un
letto biposto si dice letto biposto
letto matrimoniale lettone forte come
come con l'affermazione mazza cuore che
è bellissima questa ripresa ma guarda se
troppo giusto yo yo yo yo che fia f
ripresa
e ripresa mostruoso
grazie vi chiedo scusa per queste
chilate di merda visiva ora banco bar e
vanta un paradosso
quando a roma
la solitudine perché non a nanna
no
mi ero ripromesso di fare un sacco di
video durante il viaggio in treno ma
alla fine mi sono messo a guardare noi
che si chiama google drag race per tre
ore mi sono fatta venire l'orzaiolo agli
occhi pur di guardarlo e non ho fatto
niente
sono arrivato a roma sono qui seduto per
terra dal 20 minuti aspettando mio
fratello mi venga a prendere in questo
muletto dove almeno una
dozzine di cani avranno già fissato
negli ultimi cinque minuti benvenuto a
casa la mia ombra incombe
salve caro come vanno davanti in
quell'angolino dove mi hanno fissato
addosso labrador cani di tutte le quel
di amici stitico mai detto m'hai detto
dieci minuti fa io stavo dormendo
[Risate]
posso dire cosa credo che tu inizi ma di
essere ripreso a casa tutti si è
scordato che macchina aperta che poté ti
sei scordato la mia macchina aperta che
non l'ho uccisa
ma quanto sei venuto ad aprirla era
aperta ancora aumentato con un
normalissimo senza bisogno di aprirla
che cosa abbiamo fatto
abbiamo accolto dei randagi in questa
macchina strano che non ci sia tutto
arrivati a destinazione al posto del
volante un timore ci ammontare stanno
facendo un video carinissimo stanno
facendo un video carinissime mi ha fatto
capire che loro sono bravi a coprire un
regalo che ho ricevuto la zia piena e
non siete pronti per impazzire di lo so
a chi non lo so tu sai cos'è non lo so
io lo so maledetto macchina sì ma non
possono avere tu lo sai che bello può
sapere non bono peraltro maturità è un
po pesante per essere un modo per non
penso il mio nome
per buono ciò è comprato una cosa ci
stanno delle luci per casa si appendono
al muro e la seconda di quante ne hai tu
puoi creare delle forme incassando
facendo tutte delle cose per cui i
colori poi l'inno sinistra ne fanno le
magie bello ma è un telefono questo si
regge anche un telefono e allora dice
lei sa che viene scusami inquadra qui
c'è un colletto come tu ti sei fatto il
cinema come donatello gian luigi
ridicoli e un sede altro ma che fino
adesso film se no ti prego non si
aspetta che non si vede nella sede
tantissimo ma c'è un gatto eccolo non è
capito c'è una specie di golem gatto
sopra una luce che fissa i passanti ed è
meraviglioso e stupendo sono trovata un
po a casa ben dritta questa videocamera
volevo un attimo aprire questo cosino
qui e sinceramente non so manco perché
io sto a fa sta pubblicità sti tizi cioè
non avessero anche i venti voglio avere
la casa tappezzata di queste voci hanno
ricordato non li comprate non sono così
belli questo pezzo a me non fa ridere
invece fa ridere piccolo perché fa
ridere fa ridere perché l'area è un
unboxing di ma si capisce prove che non
sta capendo perché il panico leggeri e
paride puntiamo invece lo vediamo che si
sono così e li ha persi
a vivere con un ragno appeso al soffitto
è un ragno al quale staccato il corpo e
al momento della verità allora mettiamo
così in realtà ne ho molte altre da
attaccare ma sono troppo sono
curiosissimo di vedere che cosa succede
nel momento in cui inserisco questo così
no tac tac o no valore ora ne attacco
attacco questo così non prendo un altro
quadrato e attacca noi filo c'è anche
una nap
ma siccome sono daltonico in questo modo
non è niente male ad enrico mi daranno
guardiamo associazione vediamo la sua
lezione guerra
ma fai tipo una composizione cosa
comporre mattina i quindici indici stava
facendo una composizione è bello si
rompe se ci cammini sopra ma perché
c'era camminare sopra charities una
goccia d'acqua su questa valigia un
altro pezzo di video mostruoso ma enrico
ha riso tanto spiega perché perché
praticamente quando mi dici di spostare
la valigia e si sente come la
demolizione della casa genoa lancia
manal amati già capito e quindi a ridere
perché come una barca no se logici qua è
una barca a tipo una lumaca c'è qualcosa
di una maga allora prova a levare questo
e aggiungerla viene un pene card spetta
cerco di far vedere il pen in camera
eccolo qua è finito e che cos'è dei
montagne ceche composizione tra faccio
io una decomposizione
ok ma che cosa si fa
enrico devo ancora capire che cosa fare
una notissima zoomando cosa fare per un
attimo
io ho un'altra sorpresa tutto questo
come la troverò qualcuno ha capito che
forse sono stato un po non quest'anno è
che quindi questo natale di iniziare ad
apprezzarlo all'interno della lego e
anche questo nessuno mi sta pagando mi
hanno mandato questa roba qui è stata
mandata il 10 ottobre tipo e perché lo
aprì solo adesso perché stavano per il
fisco sbagliato a una vecchia agenzia
questa mangiata mangiata andata io che
ho detto cosa c'è dentro
no non è possibile
vediamo erigono enrico non è possibile
enrico non è possibile ma è mio dio
questo è il natale più bello del mondo e
nessuno il secondo giorno di blog mas e
si è letto harry potter scuola di magia
e stregoneria di hogwarts siamo detti
informarla che leggo leggo tavole di
informarla che leggo ha deciso di
regalarle un pizzico di magia da vivere
grazie al set lego harry potter la
preghiamo di mostrarci la sua abilità
nel costruire le ricordiamo che la magia
è proibita in presenza di bambini
[Musica]
il mio aiuto preziosissimo no alla
ufficiosi domani e mettano in tre questo
punto cosa fare domani
so già cosa fare domani io racconta
mario altri
ci vediamo domani sempre alle 14 col
blog mas numero 3 questo blog ma finisce
qui e come vi avevo promesso all'inizio
del video
avete visto 13 minuti e passa a domani